[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka multiple sort of a duplicate joke
there for fans of the comics
and this video we're breaking down
episode 4 of invincible
throughout this we're going to be
discussing the easter eggs major comic
book differences
and our thoughts on where things could
be going now i am going to be trying to
keep this as spoiler free as possible
but due to discussing some of the
changes there may be minor things that
hint towards what's going to happen in
the show
i won't reveal any of the major twists
but you might want to dive out if you're
someone who likes to go into stuff
completely blind
anyway if you're still here thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
episode 4 of invincible
okay so the episode itself has some big
deviations from the source material
and i was actually surprised early on
how much things changed
whilst the mars chapter is pretty much
the central part of issue 18
outside of that there are some really
cool change-ups that make it so you
can't predict what's coming even if you
do know the work
now we start off in egypt and see a
shady figure with a scarab tattoo on his
hand
approaching an excavation site this
scene isn't really in the comics at all
so whether it's a gag or setting things
up for the future we don't know yet
at this dig they've unearthed the tomb
of an ancient mummified godlike creature
who will bring great suffering to the
world this moment is clearly a play on
not only films involving the mummy
but i also feel that it's aping
apocalypse from the x-men franchise
apocalypse was thought to bring forth
well well the apocalypse
and this super villain came from ancient
egypt the movie x-men apocalypse
features his resurrection
and though this one is cut short due to
the tomb's slamming shot on his head
expect to see some change-ups for this
with him potentially coming back
or just being dead now whether this pays
off in the future yeah
we don't know but the episode is filled
with foreshadowing
and a lot of this comes early on as we
join mark and his father flying across
the sahara
mark flies too close to the ground and
this causes a sandstorm to arise
which is later repeated on mars when he
does something similar
beyond that the pair travel to mount
everest where they have a father and son
moment
not to get too spoilery but i'm sure you
can already surmise that mark and his
father will probably end up fighting at
some point
in issue 12 of the comics the pair end
up fighting in a snowy landscape which
is where the fight culminates
and i feel that this father and son
moment will be repeated later on in the
season
but with the pair at each other's
throats nolan brings up that humans
don't appreciate how beautiful a planet
is
and this very much justifies the
mentality that he possesses
that he should control it and decide
what they do and don't do
this is very much reflected in the
speech in which he talks about velcro
and how they as a race have ended many
wars across the universe
in nolan's eyes they have brought peace
but as we get further into the series
we learn that the world betterment
committee had some nefarious dealings
nolan is an orphan that lost his parents
and he states that his wife debbie
turned earth from a job into a home
throughout this episode we see their
relationship far more fleshed out than
it is in the comics
and also get the feeling that nolan is
wrestling with choosing his duty over
his family
the pair also race home and nolan wins
even though mark has a head start
cementing that he's far more skilled
than his son is elsewhere we join
deborah and olga
the wife of red rush who is furious at
her husband's killer has not been found
olga wants to go home and as debbie is a
real estate agent
she agrees to sell her house however
olga carries a warning that everything
isn't going to be sunshine and rainbows
like their husbands promise and this
clearly itches away at deb
she returns home and searches for damien
darkblood and it's clear that the series
is taking him in a brand new direction
i didn't even really mention him that
much in the breakdown last week because
in the comics he's pretty much just the
butt of a joke
damien is enlisted to get to the bottom
of who killed the guardians
and it becomes public knowledge exactly
what happened he then shows up down the
line and says he's cracked the case
but at this point the entire world
already knows voiced by clancy brown
this cross between hellboy in the
question has a lot more to do in this
story
and he very much surmises early on that
nolan is involved
nolan grows angry at him throughout the
episode and worried that he's going to
give the game away
cecil ends up exercising him and sending
him back to hell
now dark blood makes it clear to nolan
that deborah is starting to suspect
something
and it won't be long until mock does 2.
we later learn that nolan planted the
blood of the guardians in his office
and therefore steadman puts things in
place to make it seem like the framing
worked
even though it confirms for cecil that
he was the one behind it
now i love how cecil very much shows his
strategist side throughout this episode
and even though nolan believes he's in
the clear steadman
very much has his eye on him we also
start to see amber and mark's
relationship developing
and in the comics mark really struggled
with having to constantly rush off all
the time to help save the world
before he departed to mars she actually
started to question whether he was a
drug dealer or not
but here they keep things simple and say
he's just volunteering on a trip
amber is way more likable than how she
is in the source material i feel
as in that she she's sort of just a
ditzy blonde whereas here she seems a
lot more grounded and nuanced
could demolar who we find building
another clone i'm glad that they're
putting another one in place as the best
bits of banter in the book come from the
pair
constantly arguing over who the original
is though we don't know why he was freed
by robot just yet
going off the comics he was out for a
specific reason that i'm gonna talk
about at the end of the video
they clearly have this scene here to
show that he's a master at biology
and it does paint out he's gonna be able
to to do what robot wants basically
mauler also beefs up his brother with
bergamot patties
which are of course from the place that
mark used to work we join the new
guardians of the globe
who arrive at the headquarters which are
basically just the same as the last ones
black samson refers to how he was in
original and this annoys her explode
who's quickly becoming the comic relief
in the show
cecil clearly doesn't want any messing
around and he's left a lovely blood
stain on the wall
to remind them what could happen now
monster girl and rexplo do have a bit of
a flirt
and in the comics she falls in love with
him but he doesn't want anything to do
with her because she looks so young
monster girl is actually quite an
interesting character and we discover
that she's actually 29 years old
the monster inside of her is a curse and
every time she mutates
she gets younger whilst it gets more and
more grotesque
robot tells her explode to stay away
from her and this is actually somewhat
flipped around in the comics
the source material had him telling
monster girl to stop flirting with rex
as it makes him uncomfortable she broke
down and he offered to find a way to
help her
which involved taking a skin sample
however later on
he did also take one from rex which we
see repeated in this very moment
either way i do appreciate that things
are flipped around and we'll discuss the
eventual goal of this at the end of the
video
in case people don't want spoilers now
shortly after we see nolan having an
argument with his wife and he very much
gives the impression that he views her
as being beneath him
it's clear that deb is starting to
suspect something is up and the fact
that nolan refers to hell like this
shows how much he looks down on humanity
if he talks to his wife like this then
you can imagine how he regards the rest
of the race
and the foreshadowing here is really
really good cecil arrives
and breaks up the argument but the pair
realize that their relationship is being
strained
and they decide to go on a date they
aren't the only people getting
romantically involved either
as across town mark and amber kiss mark
returns home to find cecil who has a job
for him
which involves guarding the first manned
mission to mars
now in the source material this happened
after the fallout between mark and his
father
but here they reframe it so that cecil
can attempt to investigate nolan
whilst he's off planet this doesn't work
and mark ends up just going off on the
job himself
which is what happens in the comics due
to his father and him not getting along
jump across to adam eve in school who's
having second thoughts about the hero
lifestyle
after all she's been through she's
second guessing her choices
and has realized that life isn't all
it's cracked up to be
mark is still very much at the start of
his journey and still sees mostly good
in the business
but as he will likely discover it's not
all sunshine in rainbows
mark promises to be there for her and
this furthers the love triangle between
them
eve warns him that he has to be serious
about amber if he's gonna tell her his
identity
and in the next scene he holds back from
doing this but he does buy her
an 800 chest which let's be honest so
probably stole that yeah
if i had super speed yeah i'll just
stole it no no don't dislike the video
now mark heads out onto the shuttle
and we see that he has to have breathing
apparatus velcro mites can actually hold
their breath for two weeks
and thus him being half human has its
limitations
a hilarious moment happens when we see
the vulture s character that the
immortal tossed into space
just floating around and as the guy said
when in doubt
just toss him into space the trip itself
has several callbacks to the comics
involving not only that vulture guy bit
but also mark biting into a frozen
sandwich
which is ripped directly from the panels
we catch up to nolan who's angered by
this trip
and it's clear that he wants his sonia
to him so that he can control him
rather than having him going off and
doing his own thing deborah realizes
he's changed
and nolan tries to bury the hatchet by
taking her to her favorite restaurant
during this a dragon attacks and this
could be a callback to the comics
namely nolan's origin story when we see
him fighting one that looks a lot like
this
unlike that though he decides not to
tackle it and leaves it for cecil to
handle
now i really like debbie in this episode
as we see how she knows she's being lied
to
but rather than accepting the truth
she's happy to live in this as it keeps
us safe
on mars the explorers are taken captive
by the martians
and we're also introduced to the
sequoias a race of mind-controlling
squids that are playing on star or the
conqueror
like starro they attach to one's face
and take over someone's body
their race is capable of invading
planets once they have a host
as they become a hive mind when this
happens it becomes very clear that this
is the way the story will be going as
one
manages to attach to an astronaut named
ross whilst a martian shape-shifts and
takes his place
thus i can imagine mars being devastated
which will lead to the sequoias
journeying to the earth
now the martians of course look
extremely similar to martian man who was
a prominent member of the guardians of
the globe
based on martian manhunter that hero
came to earth because of a war on his
planet
and though this didn't involve anything
like the sequids invading it
it does line up slightly mark is taken
before the martian emperor
voiced by dimon hanzo who won some of
the dangers that the sequids pose
and he says that he must execute the
astronauts in order to be safe
mark saves them and once more this
entire scene is pulled directly from the
source material
now the human transforming does set up
shape smith
who is the character that this one
becomes it will be interesting to see if
they focus on him more in this season
as in the comics he comes a bit later
after the big ark with omniman and his
son
is done with the graysons out of town
dark blood goes through their house
and we see him rummaging through the
cupboards upstairs before he realizes
that cecil is in the property with him
the episode ends with an ominous look in
this very same cupboard
so i'm guessing that there was something
left behind by him here
mark makes it back to his mother and
father getting it on and when this
happened in the comics we realized that
mark knew what was going on
because nolan had put his shirt on
backwards when moving at super speed
mark returns and gives amber a rock from
mars as a gift
and cecil takes dark blood in to
exercise him cecil has figured out a way
to do this with his tech
and it's a big change up from what was
happening at this point in the comics
dark blood says that he won't see cecil
in hell because there's a worse place
waiting for him
probably probably justice league i'm
guessing now it is possible that he can
come back
and that he left a piece of himself
behind at the grayson's house
but i'm completely just theorizing at
the moment so let me know if you
disagree
next we join deb cleaning up olga's home
to sell it
she comes across a wedding photo of the
couple and does find joy in it
even though we know that she's very much
doomed just like how they are
deb is back to being blinded by love but
as we know
things probably aren't going to stay
that way cutter robot and this is where
we're going full spoilers yeah we're
going full spoilers from now on
so duck out of the video if you don't
want to know what's happening here
okay so if you're still here then either
you've read the comics or just want
things ruined
now in the graphic novels we watch as
robot clones a body from rex
and using the mauler twins he attempts
to put his brain into it
so he can become flesh and blood so this
is why he freed the moles
and also took the skin sample this arc
is happening
way way earlier than it did in the
comics so it's going to be interesting
to see if the fallout from that remains
either way this was another great
episode and i just want to give a huge
thank you to everyone who watched the
last breakdown
as i was absolutely blown away by the
numbers it got obviously i'd love to
your thoughts on the latest so make sure
you comment below and let me know
and also shout outs christian from
beyond epic for editing this video
thank you very much christian i know i
know you're the only one who cares about
that but
if you're commenting yet as a thank you
for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize show on
the 30th of april in which we're giving
away three copies of zack snyder's
justice league on 4k
all you have to do to be with the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our brighton of
omniman which will be linked at the end
we go over all his origins and explain
the big twist
so if if you've got an itchy corn
scratch then definitely head over there
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace